[Music]
i love jeopardy i really do but i'm i'm
starting to think alex trebek has been
hosting that show too long
i am really afraid that alex is starting
to lose it i think he's losing it take a
look
um gymnastics straight under please
despite a broken leg toby maguire nailed
this romanian girl with the over 300
year old reticulated slitherer
called the barnes
dance sounds like fun 1969
it's annoying when you blank this female
author's blank
but helpful when blank of the blank
machines use blank to make slime go
ahead make my day
tree is the willow the word is willowy
sam
slim for 800 please this ugly guy will
smith not the black one can sometimes
track down one of these irish fairies in
this type of marriage
jack spratt could eat no fat his wife
could eat no lean
mena back to you
j lo is slang for someone who
communicates by extra sensory means with
other japanese yeast exports
demeanor mike
what is whizzond wiz a minute to go now
mina slim for 2000. henry kissinger is
also known as this toothy grin fruit
searching for this fabled city of horse
tornado
that is honeysuckle
accent in this category
[Applause]
no one's
no one's stopping you i know i don't
know no one's intervening and stopping
him i don't know how those people make
any points at all